new rule in honor of the Academy Awards
show this Sunday tonight I would like to
commemorate the moment 50 years ago that
transformed the Oscar telecast into what
it is today a four-hour lecture on how
bad most people have it by the people
who have it the best
but 50 years ago an activist for Native
American causes named sasheen
littlefeather was the first person in
Oscar history to walk on that stage and
say I know this award is for acting but
I'm going to bore you with my politics
anyway
you see 1973 was the year Marlon Brando
won best actor for The Godfather and a
little late but
and instead of accepting the award
himself he sent Ms littlefeather on
stage in his place to voice what was
truly and is an important cause now for
you young people watching Marlon Brando
was an actor
Native Americans were the first people
here
all right
and The Godfather was a long Tick Tock
featuring The
featuring the horse head in the bed
challenge
[Applause]
contacts Brando had just made one of the
all-time great comebacks by playing The
Godfather and anyone else would have
eagerly shown up to the ceremony for
their Victory lap but Brando chose to
stay home for two reasons to draw
attention to Native American rights and
because like this year's Oscar favorite
the whale he was stuck in his chair
but it is how Miss littlefeather was
greeted by the Hollywood crowd that
night that interests me and the picture
of liberal Hollywood on that night may
surprise you
here's how the New York Times described
it in sasheen littlefeather's obituary
from last October at the podium she
endured A Chorus of booze drawing jeers
on stage she said that some audience
members did the tomahawk chop
a producer for the Oscars told her that
she would be arrested if her comments
lasted more than 60 seconds the actor
John Wayne was so unsettled that a show
producer said security guards had to
restrain him so that he would not storm
the stage
this was back when storming the stage
was not allowed
oh the obituary also said that little
feather recalled that while she was
giving the speech she had focused in on
the mouths and Jaws that were dropping
open in the audience and there were
quite a few now come on it's a Sheen
Little Feather made that same speech at
this year's Oscars there'd be cheers and
there would be no shocked looks on faces
and that is because of progress
[Applause]
and also Botox
foreign
but let's talk about the progress part
because people today don't seem to have
a realistic view of how progress works
for example do you know who Time
magazine's man of the year was in that
year of 1973
me neither because who cares the point
is Time Magazine was still calling the
reward The Man of the Year Time Magazine
another pillar of liberal Enlightenment
like the Oscars but it only changed the
name to person of the year in 1999.
in the Bible no one no one not God not
Jesus even considers the possibility
that slavery is wrong there are lots of
rules about it but no one ever says hey
maybe we just shouldn't do it at all
what not at all who would schlep those
giant rocks we need to make that awesome
religious stride we're making
that's where people were all people and
looking back we always wish our
forebearers would have come to progress
sooner Ronald Reagan was very late on
doing something about AIDS
but the Liberals aren't on time either
Obama was late on gay marriage JFK was
laid on civil rights Bill Clinton was
late on not having the interns blow you
foreign
I don't know if everything happens
everywhere all at once
[Applause]
but I do know that everyone is late on
everything because that's what it is to
be human Biden
is currently as we speak late on pot
and it's going to look bad in the future
the difference is the next Democrat will
legalize pot
yeah the Liberals are late like all
people are but they do tend to keep
going until we get there I'm constantly
amazed when I re-watch movies from only
a decade or so ago and they were made in
a way that today would get you burned at
the Twitter state
it's complicated from 2009 to name just
one of many I could choose was made by a
who's who of the most Blue Ribbon
certified Hollywood liberals woke
approved and Democratic party
contributing from the stars to the
producers to the director but it
apparently occurred to none of them to
have any kind of minority in the cast
you would need a divining Rod to find a
person of color within 500 feet of this
movie set
[Applause]
hahaha
but if they made it today they'd do
better when it comes to social justice
Liberals are still the tip of the spear
but even the spear comes up short a lot
they were dicks to an Indian in 1973.
and they were still blind to diversity
in 2009 but along the way
Hollywood also move the country forward
by opening people's eyes to racism
and anti-semitism
to AIDS and interracial couples and
disabilities and environmental issues
and addiction and LGBT rights and yes
the plight of the American Indian so
thank you Hollywood
have fun at the Oscars